this video is brought to you by square
space helping you make beautiful
websites quickly and easily
hey wisecrack jared here today we've got
a self-aware fourth wall breaking
spectacular for you that's right we're
talking about Deadpool Deadpool is
experiencing unprecedented popularity in
mainstream media the film is the
highest-grossing r-rated movie ever and
the biggest opening for Ryan Reynolds
but I guess that part isn't really a
surprise how is this Phil achieved such
success despite shirking the traditional
superhero formula fighting for the
greater good nope selfless not really
fun for the whole family
no for a Marvel character who's an overt
ripoff of a DC competitor who constantly
makes fun of the medium that he inhabits
the Merc with the mouth is doing pretty
well for himself
Deadpool's popularity represents a trend
in media that may be gaining steam
lately but is otherwise quite old and it
all has to do with a 400 year old book
sort of I'm an arrogant [ __ ] and
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of Deadpool part 1 achieving
[ __ ] you finally hit the bucket there
are a few defining features that set
Deadpool apart from the rest of the
Marvel Universe
he's an inveterate wiseass long sullen
silence or mean comic he knows he's a
superhero and is as a result constantly
breaking the fourth wall and commenting
on comic book tropes and culture
let's pro/con this superhero thing wrong
hey pull down a gaggle of ass local dry
cleaning discounts lucrative film deals
both origin stories and larger ensemble
teen movies Deadpool takes nothing
seriously oh the dinosaurs fear the
t-rex even the ad campaign for the film
was imagined in an entirely Deadpool ian
fashion the film's Valentine's Day ads
were simultaneously a great way to troll
soon-to-be Furious partners and a set up
for a self referential jokes they even
created a tinder profile perhaps the
best way to describe Deadpool is as a
postmodern work let me explain
post-modernism is a movement in the arts
and philosophy that typically rejects
the kind of grand narratives used to
make sense the world in the good old
days
for instance the Battle of good against
evil democracy against communism the
inherent promise of technological
progress science or divine salvation the
very idea of the good old days you get
the idea
postmodern works are quick to thumb
their nose at tradition and have a
tendency to embrace being meta and self
referential Deadpool is hyper aware of
himself and his place in the superhero
genre it sounds like a [ __ ] franchise
the film is full of Ryan Reynolds jokes
I think Ryan Reynolds got this far on a
superior acting method like the
reference to the cinematic abomination
the Green Lantern his face on People
magazine's sexiest man alive or the face
of his vastly more appreciated
counterpart also on People magazine
if the grand narrative that permeates
superhero films is the triumph of good
over evil Deadpool in good postmodern
passion says [ __ ] dude let's go bowling
I mean killing wrong movie same idea
there is no grand Battle of good over
evil just the guy out there killing a
bunch of people for revenge and love my
hero this tension between the old world
and post-modernism is played out a
couple different ways in the film
Colossus is constantly asking Deadpool
to cut out the shenanigans and join the
x-men we will make an x-men of you yet
as if to rope him into the role of the
good superhero family-friendly righteous
and so on use your powers for that be a
superhero likewise the dopinder subplot
subverts classical narratives of courtly
love win the heart of your beloved
through chivalry and compassion yeah
it's much more effective just kidnap her
current lover and stuff him in the trunk
even blind owl is essentially a deranged
version of a classic narrative deformed
protagonist who takes refuge with a
benevolent blind benefactor yep sounds
familiar except this time mr. cocaine
not to mention that the apple of our
hero's eye isn't a fair maiden she's a
prostitute turned stripper
I'm fuzzies for money yep yeah in this
way Deadpool can be seen as a spiritual
successor to a 400 year old novel that
also made fun of the heroes of its time
employed meta-narratives and is called
by some a proto postmodern work Don
Quixote remem
that the story of Don Quixote is the
tale of a fictional author who
discovered the fictional accounts of Don
Quixote a story within a story way
before the Blair Witch Project Don
Quixote understands that he's being
written about that guy over there came
in looking for you
and the fictional author retelling his
tale constantly breaks the fourth wall
at one point in Don Quixote the story
just cuts off when the fictional author
claims the rest of the story was lost
we're not saying this parallel is
intentional but it is worth noting that
Deadpool kills Don Quixote in the comic
books to grasp Don Quixote is relation
to Deadpool we have to understand its
historical context Don Quixote was
written at a time when radical
skepticism of the existing order started
to bud in popular society it was written
just before the Enlightenment gripped
Europe which would respond to this
skepticism by touting the virtues of
rationality in science but Don Quixote
wasn't setting out to invent a new
ideology he just wanted to have a few
laughs at the expense of Spanish society
Deadpool signals a similar
disenchantment with all those righteous
narratives in our society but this time
it's a little different and whether or
not it's a good thing is up for debate
no part to ironic distance and cynicism
in a recent interview Joss Whedon the
man behind such self-aware titles as
Firefly Buffy and the Avengers finds in
Indiana Jones a microcosm for all that's
wrong with today's culture in the
original Indiana Jones film our
protagonist famously deals with a
gratuitous display of swordsmanship with
a modest display of marksmanship in the
temple of doom were confronted with a
similar scene but oh my there are now
two swordsman Indy reaches for his gun
but it's not there he delivers a
shit-eating grin to the audience as it
to say see what I did there you saw the
last movie and I made an inside joke
about it I'm so glad we had this moment
together now that you feel like you're
in on this collective joke that doesn't
even make sense because Temple of Doom
is a [ __ ] prequel that moment of self
reference for the sake of self reference
Whedon says has engulfed our culture
film television literature it's all
becoming that moment for fighting an
army of robots
Navigo and arrow none of this makes
sense this self-awareness is
increasingly taking a cynical tone it's
almost everywhere you look in the new
Tarzan trailer a reboot slash remake
slash adaptation that nobody asked for
Jane overtly references the fact that
she's playing the tired role of a damsel
in distress
screen for me now what really chaps my
ass about this is that the film is
recognizing that it's using tired
recycled tropes but instead of doing
something new
it simply apologizes for it and expects
us to perceive this self-awareness as
something clever and new rambo is a plus
the end of star trek into darkness is
just an excuse to say hey remember this
great scene in cinema now it's opposite
day 22 Jump Street is the exact same
plot as 21 Jump Street but it's okay
because we can all collectively identify
with Ice Cube for calling them out on
their [ __ ] it's the same taste do
the same day or as South Park frames it
it's Jim Carrey in whatever you'll pay
to go see it you July 12 as a 2-out
Mehta eachother the cynical attitude has
transcended self-reference into
self-effacement Hollywood that decrepit
machine fueled by the ideas of
yesteryear is always stuck referencing
itself I swear to God I will find in the
next life and I'm a boombox Careless
Whisper outside your window in an effort
to reinvent itself while still remaining
the same it gleefully acknowledges it's
lazy cliches with a wink and a nod
I think it's happened again like in
Tarzan or by employing irony to undercut
a dramatic moment we're all standing up
now bunch of jackasses standing in a
circle
Deadpool does both he breaks the fourth
wall to let us in on the joke and an
avoid serious drama like the plague I
was molested me too okay uncle's
Hollywood still employs familiar
structures and tropes but distance is
the audience from any kind of sincerity
so that it feels new I just want to get
to know that Sabrina use not the
two-dimensional sex object peddled by
Hollywood
yeah is this Hollywood version of
hashtag sorry not sorry gratifying for
the viewer or have we just come to terms
with the fact that there's nothing new
to say Deadpool's humor is largely
driven by this sense of cynicism and
ironic distance whether he's being
tortured or about to be gruesomely
maimed did I leave the stove on Deadpool
remains unfazed in the face of what
would normally be considered high-stakes
situations even the tension to combat
scenes are undercut by self-aware humor
really rolling up the sleeves also you
can't die so that probably helps if
Deadpool is immune to criticism it's
because he's defined by cynicism he
relentlessly deconstructs any trope that
would endow meaning to the film not his
blind wait no you're blind
Deadpool is more or less swayed Wilson's
journey to become hot again catching him
is my only chance to be hot again itself
a shallow endeavor even if to reclaim
his lost love or really Loess face you'd
be happy to cinema deadpool evades
criticism because he has no moral
scruples or values to defend the way
weak
his identity is purely reactionary he
risks nothing he just makes fun of
everything okay guys let's get out there
and make a difference
Deadpool doesn't claim to be a good guy
the film has zero [ __ ] to give it's ad
campaign doesn't take itself seriously
and the movie points out its own glaring
flaws the overuse of superhero tropes
superhero landing you're gonna do a
superhero laughing or the obvious
budgetary constraints it's almost like
the studio couldn't afford another x-men
I mean negasonic teenage warhead is the
Marvel Universe equivalent of a Walmart
bargain bin DVD negasonic teenage what
yes but just because the movie is aware
of and sort of apologizes for its
lacking qualities does that make it good
I have to admit I'm conflicted here on
the one hand I find Deadpool's
self-reflective edgy commentary to be
undeniably enjoyable at the end of the
day Ryan Reynolds is damn charming the
action is awesome and the jokes are
disarming and quite fun but then again
should we really give so much praise to
a movie that essentially functions like
an honest trailer for other comic-book
movies
therein lies the danger with this trend
it never creates anything an obsession
with being meta that devolves into an
endless spiral of meta
fourth-wall break inside a fourth-wall
break that's like 16 walls in this way
Deadpool isn't entirely dissimilar from
another cultural movement one that
ironically loves the cliche endlessly
recycles culture and constantly
positions itself against the mainstream
hipsters as Douglass had Al once aptly
noted the danger of the hipster is the
end of Western civilization itself a
culture lost in a superficiality of its
past and unable to create any new
meaning
Deadpool isn't reinventing the superhero
genre it can only exist to make fun of
the genre let's go to talk to the
breakfast McAvoy or Stewart these
timelines are so confusing
here's the real problem with Deadpool
and other films like it bashing the
system may feel good it may make us
laugh but it's ultimately powerless it
doesn't change the system at all as our
old friend and alleged Mark Hamill body
double slab Boise check notes cynical
distance laughter irony are so to speak
part of the game the ruling ideology is
not meant to be taken seriously or
literally hipsters fancy themselves
members of the counterculture by
drinking PBR and having ironic mustaches
Deadpool fancies itself a
countercultural movie by celebrating its
own played out cliches in an overused
storyline essentially the cinematic
equivalents of gross hipster moustaches
and non-prescription glasses this
cultural impasse reflects the society
that doesn't quite know what to do with
itself we beat the commies our music
film and literature dominate the world
market and as a society we're not
exactly on the brink of collapse despite
what political pundits are telling you
if Deadpool can say [ __ ] it it's because
he doesn't fear death how can he take
anything seriously if there are no
consequences can life be sacred when
it's become limitless I got the cure to
El everything he'll if the superhero
genre survived these dumpster fires then
maybe it can't die either so [ __ ] it why
not break all the rules here the music
interestingly the very sanctity breaking
of the comic book was inspired by a
similar problem except rather than
feeling that Deadpool the comic was
uncountable they felt it would be
canceled at any minute what ensued was a
similar attitude of [ __ ] if the comic
was already dead why not write it like
nothing mattered if we as a society can
say [ __ ] it perhaps it's because death
or any real existential threat has
become either so distant or so close
that we no longer care so where does
Deadpool land in our cultural landscape
does it just use the fourth wall
breaking to put a shiny makeover on the
same old [ __ ] is it the ultimate cynical
film or does it actually achieve
something new it's over
well let us know what you think in the
comments unlike Deadpool wisecrack isn't
immortal we depend on the amazing
support of our sponsors like Squarespace
to keep making great content for y'all
Squarespace has made it easy for anyone
to make a smokin website and they're
giving you 10% off your first order when
you use the offer code wise Kraft
they've got tons of beautiful templates
that make creating your own website easy
and because the folks at Squarespace are
so damn cool they're giving you a free
14-day trial - see for yourself
so go to Squarespace comm slash
wisecrack or use the link in the
description below to sign up today
make sure to use the offer code
wisecrack to get 10% off your order and
we're constantly working on new videos
so poke Deadpool's chimichanga and
you'll be taken to our channel page
where you can check out our other videos
and hit the subscribe button if you
haven't already I mean it wouldn't be a
bad idea
as always thanks for watching peace
[Music]